[Music]
foreign
so in this video I want to give a really
quick high level intro to how to use
Python for engineering math scientific
Computing just really kind of quick and
dirty what are the first few commands
you need to get under your belt to do
simple things like for loops and while
Loops making matrices and vectors and
multiplying them and maybe even things
like integrating uh you know the
trajectory of some ordinary differential
equation so stuff that you'll definitely
use in an engineering math class that
hopefully I can cover pretty quickly
just running through this script so this
this Jupiter notebook was written by
Alan Captain ogloo to provide this high
level intro to python for the kind of
intrograduate engineering math class
that we're co-teaching and so I'm just
going to kind of walk through it and
we'll we'll talk through some of you'll
basically see some of the the basic
operations and things that you should be
able to do in Python this is by no means
extensive this is is not you know pie
torture tensorflow or anything you know
more advanced than just you know how do
you add numbers and build matrices and
plot things and stuff like that
and so you know
this is assuming that you have python
installed so you can do this with
something like anaconda or pip install
or there's a lot of ways of doing this
you know if you Google how to install
python you'll find a lot of great
resources on how to install python
um and I'm also assuming that you have
this kind of Jupiter notebook
environment so you can fire up a Jupiter
notebook you can open this python
introduction and you can follow along if
you like
um and something you know I think Alan
and I both think is really important for
you to to recognize is that the indexing
in Python starts at zero so if you have
a vector the the first element of that
Vector is that Vector of zero the so
zero in this index is the first element
and then the you know one is the second
element two is the third element and so
on and so forth so that takes a little
getting used to if you're used to
something like Matlab where the indexing
starts at one okay but you'll get used
to it pretty quickly and python is a
much more powerful language so I'm also
kind of assuming you know maybe you want
to Learn Python but you have some
experience in Matlab or some other
language
um
python is an extremely powerful General
language it's an interpreted language
which means it's not pre-compiled but
it's built on a lot of compiled
libraries so there's a lot of really
powerful stuff under the hood and it can
do almost anything but you need to you
know know where to look and which
libraries to import into the python
environment to use them so fortunately
basic math is built in so you know the
basic mathematical operations like
addition two plus two two times two two
divided by two two minus two times seven
is going to do the same order of
operations that you think it should it's
going to multiply 2 times 7 first and
then subtract that from two similarly
you can put parentheses around things
two minus two quantity times seven is
going to be 0 times 7 should return 0.
and if you didn't put what print here it
will do that calculation but it won't
print anything to the screen so you need
to print to actually put an output onto
the screen
so like for example if I just did
something silly here and I said two plus
two and I hit enter
well I guess in this case it does print
so maybe this is uh you know maybe maybe
I was wrong so two plus two does print
if I did 2 minus 2 times 7 that's zero
but what if I do two plus two after
so here notice if I put two commands
it'll only print the last command
computed unless I say print print print
print print print okay so that's why
we're doing that there but basic math
you know you don't need to import any
libraries and it's kind of exactly how
you would expect it to be
um multiplication is the asterisk sign
so two times two should give me four
if I want to do something to the power
that's a little different it's not 2
carat three to get 2 to the power three
if I wanted 2 to the power of 3 I would
say 2 star star three and that would be
2 to the power 3 which is eight okay so
that's another important thing to note
here is that something to the power is
to star star that power
good
um okay and you can also assign
variables like I'm doing down here using
the at symbol so no big deal you can say
a equals two plus two and again I'm
pretty sure if I just say two you know
let me see if I can go here and say a
equals two plus two and I hit enter it's
not going to print anything
I may have uh let me make sure I did
this
it's not going to print anything because
it's it's you know assigning that
information to that variable a and it
doesn't think it needs to print anything
and so I have to explicitly say print a
to get the output of that you know a
equals two plus two and again if you're
you know used to Matlab normally you'd
have to put a semicolon after something
to suppress the output so it doesn't
output to the screen here it's not going
to Output unless you tell it to print
that thing okay so that's uh that's kind
of useful okay good so you can add
numbers multiply numbers take numbers to
the power you can assign variables
equals to mathematical operations you
can do mathematical operations and then
assign those to a variable a
what about for loops and while loops and
things like that those are super
important so here we're going to write a
little Loop that counts all of the
numbers from 1 to 10.
and so uh the that that count is going
to be stored in this count equals zero
so we're starting off by initializing
this variable to zero and then we're
going to write a for Loop for this dummy
variable i i in the range of 10. so this
is the quick and dirty python way of
saying for i i in the range from 1 to 10
in increments of one this literally
means for i i in
um you know one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten I think is what
what that literally means
um
it's going to count it's going to add II
to the count and then it's going to go
you know for for all II in this range
from 1 to 10 it's going to add that III
to count and then at the very end it's
going to print this count and you'll
notice when you do a for Loop you do 4
II in range of something this
technically this for Loop doesn't have
to be a numeric for Loop it doesn't have
to be 4 k equals one to ten it could be
4K in a list of
of strings do things with those strings
like it's a much more general for loop
it's for II in any set of objects
whether they're numbers or strings or
arrays or whatever and so here range of
10 just creates a set probably indexed
at zero because it's python so probably
zero one two three four dot dot dot
um and if I wanted to test this I guess
what I would do is I would just say
range
of 10.
and maybe I would say print
range of 10.
uh
maybe I'll say
k equals range of 10. let's hope this
works and then I'll say print
k
okay so I'm not it's not going to print
them out for me but essentially uh here
I'll do it this way I'll say
um
4ii in range of 10 colon
print II okay that's what I want to do
so now I'm going to run that and it's
printing 0
all the way down to nine okay so it's
actually only added up the first nine
entries so so range 10 gives you a
vector from 0 to 9. so 10 so it's a
vector of length 10 starting at zero
starting at index 0 going up to you know
up to up to index nine okay so that's
what that I I in range of 10 does you'll
notice when you end a for Loop you put a
semicolon there and hit enter and it
automatically indents for you so it
tells you that anything that's indented
is going to be part of that for Loop and
then when you're done with what that for
Loop is supposed to be you don't have to
say end for Loop or anything like that
you just remove your indentation and it
knows that only everything inside of
that indented text is part of that for
Loop
okay so um
let's try this here
um
so we run this this code for iin range
10 add up all of those numbers I'm
actually pretty sure this is just the
sum of the numbers one to nine we could
probably do this in our head pretty
quickly and come up with yes in fact one
plus nine is ten two plus eight is ten
three plus seven is ten four plus six is
ten that's 40 plus the five in the
middle is 45. this is actually only
adding up all of the numbers from uh
it's adding up the numbers from nine
from zero to nine the way I've written
it here
if I wanted to add up the numbers from 1
to 10
from 1 to 10 what I would actually do is
I would add count plus one to each of
these uh sorry I would add II plus one
to all of my counts so for each of these
II starting from 0 to 9 I could just add
one to those to make it from one to ten
okay so again in Python because it
starts at the index 0 this list is only
zero to nine it has ten elements but
it's only zero to nine so if I wanted to
add up one to ten I would just add one
to all of those numbers so I I plus 1
plus count and this should be 55 which
is the actual sum of all the numbers
from 1 to 10.
55 good okay we already found a bug
we're feeling good about this and it's
because we actually went up here and
actually you know looked at what II in
range of 10 outputs outputs this list
from zero to nine and so again if I
wanted to add up the numbers from 1 to
10 I would need to add up I I plus one
which is now a list from 1 to 10. good
okay so we can do four Loops we can add
things to a counter we can use this cool
range command to just create a big
Vector right off the bat that's nice
um
similarly you could do something like
subtract numbers until the count is not
greater than 10. so that's kind of cool
so you could start with this counter
equals count which starts at 55.
and
um
let's count yeah count is 55 so I could
have another variable called counter
that starts at 55 and I could subtract 1
from that counter until counter is not
you know while the counter is greater
than 10 it starts up at 55. so while
it's bigger than 10 I subtract 1. it'll
be 54. then you know it's still bigger
than 10 so I've checked another one
it'll be 53. still bigger than 10 I
subtract another one it'll be 52 and
this will repeat until my counter is not
greater than 10 okay so it'll probably
subtract it down until it is exactly
equal to 10. and so I'll run this
um
and yes in fact it does subtract my
counter down until it is exactly equal
to 10. if I wanted greater than or equal
I would just put greater equal okay no
big deal so you can do four Loops you
can do while Loops all of that is kind
of built in
um now let's go to vectors and arrays so
there are some built-in array and Vector
classes in Python you can just create a
vector with you know square brackets and
commas this will create a vector one two
three four
um
and you know uh you can access the
elements of that Vector the the tooth
element is actually the third element
because it's indexed at zero so for
example
you know my Vector let's say it has one
two three four the indexing this is the
zeroth index the first index the second
index and the third index so if I take
like my Vector a vector
uh of of two
that's actually this you know that's not
the second entry that's actually the
third entry because it starts at zero
zero one two the a vector of two is
going to return
um you know that's going to return
the value three okay so you have to
really keep
um keep those things in mind here when
you're when you're working with these
these python arrays
um
these built-in arrays that much I use
numpy arrays so these are really really
powerful numpy is the numerical python
Library it is extremely well supported
it's very very powerful it's built on
super high-end linear algebra algorithms
and so generally speaking in in my my
python codes the first line is import
numpy as NP and what that does is that
Imports into the name space of this
uh everything below here all the
functionality is numpy so um you know
every every command in numpy is going to
be imported into this namespace and all
you and what it means when you say as NP
uh normally you would have to type numpy
dot ones of four to create a vector of
ones when you import numpy as NP you can
use the shorthand NP dot ones and so it
just makes your your code a little bit
more Compact and a little bit shorter
you technically could say import numpy
as asterisks and it would just bring in
all of that namespace and you wouldn't
even have to type NP dot but that's a
really kind of dangerous I idea it's
almost like defining Global variables
it'll just kind of like overwrite
anything in your namespace that has the
same name as an NP function a numpy
function so this is pretty common most
people do this they import numpy as NP
and so everybody uses the shorthand NP
dot all of the commands in numpy in the
numpy package and so for example you
know easy to create a vector of ones and
P dot ones of four creates a vector with
four ones in it you can create an NP
array of one comma two comma three comma
four just like this this Vector here to
create a vector
um you can create matrices I actually
think this npra is going to be a row
Vector
because it's commas are going to give me
a row vector and if I want to build a
matrix
it's this um again it's an NP array but
it's an array of arrays so you'll notice
that there are two square brackets here
and so what this is doing is it's
essentially adding in this first row
Vector one two three four and then this
next row Vector 5 6. seven eight and I
hope I'm doing this correctly I'm going
to copy this code and we're going to
print this just to make sure I'm not
telling you something that's wrong
let me add some code here
so I'm going to import numpy as NP I'm
going to create these vectors and I'm
just going to print them out so that we
can see kind of what's what's happening
and maybe I'll add some more lines here
okay so I'm going to do something like
print
B vector
okay so it is in fact a row Vector of
ones uh if I print uh if I print my a
vector it's again going to be a row
Vector just like I suspected and so that
makes me think that this a matrix is
going to be a two by four Matrix because
it's essentially
two row vectors stacked on top of each
other
so if I do my a matrix
again it's this two by four a matrix and
you can do things like get the size of
this Matrix into a little Tuple of
numbers the row size and the column size
you know for all of this stuff python is
extremely well documented so if you just
do a quick Google numpy size of an array
you're going to find the exact command
that spits out the size of this array
really easy stuff
um good so um I use numpy arrays pretty
often for uh for things like this
um
good
what else uh okay so Matrix Vector
operation is really important if you
want to multiply two matrices or you
want to multiply a matrix by a vector
it's not the asterisk sign or a Time
sign it's the at sign this this uh the
at sign and so you know a matrix times a
vector is literally
um you know would would literally be the
product of these things and I'm pretty
sure that in this case it's going to
interpret even though it looked like a
row Vector it's going to interpret this
as a column Vector for the purposes of
Matrix Vector products and so you'll
have to get used to how kind of uh
python you know indexes these arrays and
what can be multiplied and if you do
this a little bit you know if you spend
any time writing codes involving
matrices and vectors you'll get really
good at making sure the sizes in an
array indices match up
um good yeah and so
um this dot shape command is how you
access that dimension of these NP
objects so if we do let's go back up
here and we say
a matrix dot shape
that should spit out yes in fact this is
a two by four Matrix let's try a
vector.shape I'm just curious what it
says a vector dot shape
is a four by a comma so it's interesting
it's not actually saying that this
Vector is a row vector or a column
Vector it's just saying it's a vector it
has four entries comma whatever and this
is actually kind of clever because what
it means is that even though when I
output when I printed my a vector it
printed it like it looked like a little
row Vector one two three four
If I multiply this a vector by a matrix
that's this size it's going to interpret
that as a column Vector because that'll
be the only shape that would make sense
to multiply this by this and so that's
kind of cool that you can actually see
it's not a four comma one vector or a
one comma four Vector like you would
have in in some other languages it
literally is a vector class and it's
something different
okay good
um
what else
um okay if you want to do an element
wise squares so like I want to take
every single element of this Matrix and
square each of them so this would be a
new Matrix 1 4 9 16 25 36 49 64. you
would similarly do my a matrix star star
2 that'll take the the square the second
power of every single element of that
Matrix so it'll do an element-wise
operation which is kind of cool
and you see here actually yeah this is
the element wise Square here good
um anything else I want to show you
um
maybe let me look at this Matrix Vector
product again because I'm curious uh
what this is going to do so I think that
this should give a two by one
uh Vector so if I do this
my Matrix Vector product
and maybe I need to print
my matte VEC
product
okay and in fact it is an array of 30 by
70. okay because
um if I took a a four by one vector
times this it's going to give me a two
by one vector out again it's irritating
me that it draws these as row vectors
you'll have to get used to that if I do
something like what is matte VEC product
dot shape
[Music]
um
it is again it's a vector it's not it's
not a two by one array or a one by two
array it is a vector because it's a it's
a matrix Vector product and the output
of that is a vector with size two and of
course you'll have to realize yes in
fact if I multiply a two by four matrix
by a four Vector I have to get a two
Vector out so it's a two Vector but it's
not it's not specifying it as a column
vector or a row Vector it's just saying
it's a vector okay so you'll have to get
used to that
um good what else
um so sometimes we're going to want to
integrate things over a Time Vector
we'll want to compute a Time vector or a
spacecraft Vector kind of a a grid of
points you know uniformly spaced between
zero and and T or a and b or whatever
and so the command again is
numpy.linspace so in general it would be
numpy.linspace but since we've imported
numpy as NP it's NP Dot linspace and so
what this does is again this is all in
the comments here maybe I'll make this a
little bit bigger so you can read this
without me
scrolling so this creates a 200 element
Vector a 200 dimensional Vector
on the interval minus 100 to 100 again
uniformly spaced so 200 elements
uniformly spaced for minus 100 to 100
that's what Lin space is going to do
very very useful
um command here maybe I'll just um
create a little uh entry here so we can
play around with this so let's say the
time equals NP dot Lin space from minus
one to one in increments of 10 or sorry
10 elements
uh let's run that and then let's print
the time
so you can see that what this is going
to do is it's creating
um so let's just count one two three
four five six
seven eight nine ten okay good so it it
returns an array with length 10 of
points uniformly spaced between negative
one and one and you'll notice that this
is uh the spacing is a little gnarly
it's like spacing of 0.22222 repeating
you know two ninths if you really wanted
this to be an even space you wouldn't
have picked 10 points you would have
picked 11 points so if I wanted 11
points between here
now I'll get a nice you know even
spacing of 0.2 minus one minus point
eight minus point six point four point
two zero zero point two point four point
six point eight and one and again uh
there are 11 points
spaced 0.2 apart between negative one
and one so this is how you create like a
Time Vector if I wanted better
resolution I would just say Okay I want
101 points and that's going to give me a
big
you know grid from negative one to one a
hundred and one points and you'll have
to figure out how if I wanted to specify
the DT you know you would have to
specify like um
you'd have you'd have to kind of build
in that DT here to build that number so
you know if I wanted something like
um
I know that the length of my interval is
2. and I if I wanted a DT of you know
0.01 I would do 2 divided by 0.01
plus 1 because I want that to be the
spacing and if I run this oh something
terrible happened
um
let's see if I can do this without
no uh okay so the issue is that if I do
2 divided by 0.01 it's returning a float
and this entry here can't have a float
it means an integer this only is defined
for integer divisions and so I totally
killed this code here
um because I was trying to be too clever
and try to make this
um
a different a different uh gradation so
if I wanted this to be in spacing of 0.1
I would need 201 points
um 201 points
and that'll work there I'm pretty sure
you can cast your float into an integer
using something like the ceiling command
or the floor command uh if I do this
live I'm definitely going to mess this
up I'll try np.floor because I'm almost
sure there's a floor function
that didn't like that at all
um and let's just see what the you know
a float object cannot be interpreted as
an integer okay so even floor is
apparently returning something let's try
NP dot int
of 201 that's fine so let's see if I can
now cast this as an integer and and so
if I do if I take a floating Point
number like a decimal number it's not an
integer they're stored in different
array like a different um they're stored
as different objects in Python and so
this is expecting an integer for the
number of points in this uh this lens
space this linear space
and so I think if I do something like
what I did before which is you know uh
two divided by 0.01 that quantity plus
one
python thinks that this is a floating
Point number because I took and divided
by a floating Point number and
generically that will have decimal
representation even though we know that
this has a is exactly a 201 it's going
to interpret that as
201.000 and so I'm going to recast that
as an integer and hope that I don't
break my code ah and it worked beautiful
okay so this is how you would kind of
Hack That Lin space if you wanted
exactly spacing a 0.01 you could do it
this way instead of specifying that I
want 201 points you could compute how
many points it should have for this
spacing of 0.01 but you'd have to take
that and recast that as an integer or
else you're going to break your code so
python is incredibly powerful it's
incredibly General and it is actually
good that all of these different number
types are stored as different objects
because there's different algorithms for
computing on integers versus floating
points and things like that and in fact
if your code is really expecting an
integer it should throw a flag or
something it should throw an exception
if you try to give it something that's
not an integer like it doesn't make any
sense to have a linear spacing from
minus one to one with 1.2
points like what does it mean to have
1.2 points it doesn't mean anything so
it should this should crash this should
crash and give you an error okay because
it's trying to use a float when it
should be getting an integer
and so you got to work around those
things so it's both nice and a little
bit irritating that uh it throws these
exceptions when you do something stupid
but
uh you'll get used to how to kind of
work around this and be very precise and
uptight and you know for example cast
these things as integers like I did
before
um you know so so this this code here I
kind of want to show you how I think on
the Fly also when I'm when I'm doing
this okay good
um so that's what we're doing we're
creating a Lin space uh now you know 200
elements from time minus 100 to 100
um into this the time vector and then we
can do things like compute uh you know t
squared times sine of T that would be
you know literally T every element
squared times sine of T and this uh star
here again is going to do element by
element multiplication so it's not
taking like a vector inner product of of
this vector and this Vector what it's
doing is it's going to do an
element-wise product of at each element
of my time vector
squared it's going to take that element
times each element of my sine of the
time Vector okay and similarly t squared
is just the time star star 2.
good
a couple other things you know
oftentimes you're going to want to plot
your results so a big part of scientific
Computing and engineering math is as
you're running your computations you
kind of want to plot things as you go
you can debug things you can understand
if things are intuitively working the
way you think they can you can plot your
functions and data and so it's really
good to to get very comfortable with
always plotting things fast and uh and
just just plotting your data and
plotting your functions and so in Python
the matte plot lib Library very powerful
you can do almost anything in matplotlib
if you know how so again you know Google
is your friend you're going to want to
be searching how do you do things in
matplotlib how do I plot a
three-dimensional function how do I do a
scatter plot how do I do a waterfall
plot how do I do a surface plot all of
that lives inside matplotlib if you know
where to to find it and so we're
importing from matplotlib which is a
huge package of plotting we're importing
a sub pack package Pi plot which is
going to be kind of our basic quick and
dirty plots that we're going to use
things like you know 1D and 2D line
plots we're going to import
as PLT so I don't have to type so much
so I don't have to do like if I didn't
have this line here if I just said
import matplotlib as matplotlib
then I would have to type things like
you know matte plot lib dot Pi plot dot
figure and I'm gonna my fingers are
gonna get tired okay I need to conserve
my energy here so we're going to import
this sub package as plot and then all I
have to do is just say
uh plt.figure okay so it kind of tells
this environment that anything in this
this Pi plot sub package of matplotlib
can be referenced by PLT dot that that
function
okay and so uh matplotlib super powerful
and then um you know we can plot
functions pretty easily so we created
that the time vector and we created our
um our our sine Vector
um
sine times t squared was F1 and
um t squared was F2 and so it's really
easy to plot these you literally plot uh
you know your first component versus
your second component so like T versus F
of T and then you can specify things
like what color you want it to be what
lines thickness you want it to be so
line width equals two means it's a
little bit thicker than normal it'll be
two points or pixels of line width R
Dash means a solid red curve now you can
see that this is cyan because I've
inverted my color scheme so this should
be red if I flipped it and K dash dash
means a dashed black line again because
I inverted my color scheme it is a
dashed white line so really easy to plot
things using matplotlib pi plot
you can do things like add labels you
can have the time label to the x-axis
add the functions label to the y-axis
you can add a legend for F1 and F2 R2
functions and you can add a grid you can
see it's a little faint here but there
is a little faint white grid actually
when I move my hands you can see it
better and you can do things like add
add titles and if you don't do plot dot
show it won't show any of this up it'll
just create this object in its memory
banks and it's happy to just do that all
internally again because python is a
very powerful language it's it's kind of
default is to compute things in memory
and to crankthrough computations and it
only shows you output when you ask it to
show you output plot.show
okay um and that's kind of what you're
going to want to do in general is
compute things build vectors evaluate
functions of vectors plot those things
always label your plots or else you're
going to get into trouble
um you know like labeling your plots is
the best way to look Smart in a
presentation when you're showing someone
preliminary data label your axes and
then it'll be really easy for for people
to follow along with you
okay just a couple of last things
systems of equations are really
important so like sometimes we want to
solve things like uh you know a x equals
B
uh kind of systems of equations where
maybe a is a matrix and is known this is
a matrix maybe B is a vector and is
known uh what if I want to solve
for x
we do this all the time this is like a
Mainstay of scientific Computing and
engineering math is how do you solve for
this this x sorry solve for x this x
Vector that's unknown
so again we can create numpy arrays for
a and an Umpire array for B and it's
pretty easy to solve for x using this
least squares command so this is inside
of a sub package of numpy called Lin
alge this Lin alge is going to be one of
your best friends linear algebra like
all the linear algebra stuff is in NP
dot lineage numpy.lin alge and least
squares is basically finding the x that
solves in a least Square sense ax equal
ax equals B
and so in particular this X
sorry there's some noise behind me uh
this this system doesn't even have to
have a solution there could be bees for
which this doesn't have a solution this
will find the x that minimizes ax minus
B the two Norm this will find the least
Square solution so even if this is not a
square Matrix a if it's kind of
underdetermined or over determined or
there are no Solutions it'll find the
best solution in a least Square sense so
very very powerful that's that's what
this is going to do
I kind of want to actually run this uh
up here before
um doing the next thing so I'm just
going to plot all of this
and so you can see
um you know this output print ax minus b
equals so you can print a string and
then you can print the uh the kind of
the output and so we solved
using this least squares command and
notice these underscore underscore
underscore that means that this command
could output more information I don't
know exactly what more information it
would output but if you put in you know
other variables here there are other
things that this this function could
return but we only care about the X the
solution acts we don't care about what
those other three things are and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
check okay we solved for x given this A
and B if I plug X back in if I take a
times x minus B how big is the error in
my fit and that's what I'm printing out
here and so it says a x minus b equals
two extremely small numbers nearly
machine Precision 10 to the minus 16 10
to the minus 15 which is basically
saying this x value actually does solve
this equation it is a solution of this
equation and when you plug it in you get
something that's approximately zero
because ax minus b equals 0 for that X
so this is really good
um what other things you can create
random arrays which is nice you can
create again in numpy there is a random
function so you can create a Rand end
that means a normally distributed random
variable a gaussian random and 100 by
100 means I'm going to create a big 100
by 100 array where every element is a
Rand and a univ a gaussian normal
distributed random number a gaussian
random number in random similarly I can
create a vector of random numbers by
only giving it you know one argument 100
so that's going to create a hundred
Vector of Rand ends or of normally
distributed random variables I'm pretty
sure if I got rid of this n and just did
Rand it would give me a uniformly
distributed random variable
um and you know again if you Google
numpy.random you'll find all of those
all of the the sub functions inside of
of random you'll figure out how to use
all of this stuff and again I can find
the least squares of ax equals B for
this huge 100 by 100 random Matrix and
this hundred by one random vector and
similarly solve for here again very very
small errors because this is a very good
fit
um good uh probably the last thing I
want to show you is just how to do
integration of ordinary differential
equations so
um I've shown you a lot of numpy which
is very very powerful there's also a
package called scipy and there's
multiple numerical integrators in Python
so you're going to want to just Google
you know numerical integrators in Python
and pick your favorite
um side Pi is a is similar to numpy it's
a big package of things that are useful
for scientific Computing and inside Pi
dot integrate there is this solve ivp
which is literally stands for solve
initial value problem so if you have an
initial value problem is literally x dot
equals f of x where you specify some
initial value some initial condition
exit time 0 is X naught and so solve ivp
will numerically solve this using
internal schemes that are pre-coded like
runga cut a fourth order and things like
that and there's different numerical
schemes for stiff ordinary differential
equations or all-purpose integrators
like runga cut a fourth order which is
what I usually use and I'll talk about
all of those later in this this series
but good for you to just know that you
know solve ibp has that
so similarly I can create a a Time
Vector using linspace from time 0 to 10
a thousand time points in that interval
we can create an initial condition
Vector that's our X naught and then we
can create some ode right hand side
literally this
um this f of x right hand side is ode
test this function and it takes in an
argument time comma X and it'll spit out
so this is a two-dimensional ordinary
differential equation this is a vector X
and a vector f
and so you know X One Dot and x 2 dot
are equal to you know X One Dot is X2
because again the indexing uh starts at
zero so this is actually my second
element X2 and X2 dot equals this minus
Lambda
X
minus uh Zeta
X2 sorry X1 and X2 so basically this is
how you create a right hand side
function that's going to be the right
hand side of my differential equation
and it's really easy to integrate that
using solve ivp you plug in so it's
expecting a certain set of arguments in
a certain order it's expecting an ode
test sorry an ode function the right
hand side function which we defined here
and it expects that function to be a
function of T comma X
this particular function doesn't vary in
time but this is a very general
integrator that could integrate
functions that do vary in time so it's
expecting a function of time comma space
even if it doesn't depend on time you
just say it does and then don't have it
depend on time that's fine so it's
expecting the right hand side of the ode
some time span to integrate over some
initial condition and then what time
values what Vector of times to evaluate
this trajectory on and when you run that
you get this output from ode test
solution you basically get
the output
um in this this dot y vector and I guess
we're doing a DOT T because I think we
need to like transpose this thing and
then you can plot your trajectory again
you can plot you know the time versus
Space solution for position and velocity
um and you'll get something cool like
this this is the solution of that
ordinary differential equation in
position and velocity so really
to kind of get started coding up
differential equations simulating those
differential equations even if they're
non-linear this would totally work and
then again very easy to plot these
things using using matplotlibs pi plot
so you can get started and um
if you just wanted to plot the position
that's also fine here you would just
plot the kind of
zeroth uh
what is this rows and columns yeah you
just plot the the zeroth kind of column
of this output and the the one column
would be the velocity so uh yeah so so
X1 is just the the zeroth column of this
X2 would be the the ones column on this
and you could plot either of those or
both of those and you can add Legends
and labels and all of that stuff so I
hope this gives you kind of a high level
intro to how to you know add numbers
multiply numbers create vectors create
matrices multiply them solve systems of
equations you know solve differential
equations x dot equals f of x integrate
those and then plot things
that's not everything that's a tiny tiny
minuscule fraction of what you can do in
Python but that's enough to get you
started in scientific Computing and
engineering math and you'll pick up the
rest as you go get good at the basics
and when you need things you'll know how
to Google them and piece these things
together into much bigger kind of
fancier codes and numerical
demonstrations okay I hope that was
helpful and again thanks to Alan for
putting this great package together
again you can download this in the the
links to the
in the description below below okay
thank you
[Music]